hello friends family or at least
subscribers on the internet that don't
entirely hate the sound of my voice how
you doing I thank you all right I know
there are a few things that you want me
to talk about a couple of trailers that
came out that you guys want me to do
reviews on I'm gonna talk about the one
that really spoke to my soul
that's the trailer to wreck-it Ralph
wreck-it Ralph is about wreck-it Ralph
he's a video game character from an 80s
arcade game it's pretty much like the
human version of rampage Jesus beats the
out of buildings and then he's like
you know what I've done this for so long
I don't want to be a bad guy anymore
then you see him at this little bad guy
Anonymous meeting and that's when the
trailer was like all right I'm in this
is too awesome
it's morning what you're about to see
might make your inner nerd freak out and
just go apeshit I'm just saying you've
been warned we've all felt what you're
feeling I'm Zangief I'm bad guy Ralph
you are bad guy but this does not mean
your bed guy when I saw that I was like
those are so many copyrighted characters
I love that it could have just as easily
through in some grade be Zangief or
grade B Bowser but they didn't those are
the real actual characters let me you
know real as in they're fake but you
know what I mean it's then and then it
takes it one step further and legit
sound effects I don't want to be the bad
guy anymore
yeah I had a lot of coffee today now for
that record Ralph's like you know what I
don't want to be a villain anymore I'm
leaving my game and he goes game hopping
that's the premise of the movie he goes
game hopping from game to game now I
think this is when the movies gonna get
a little generic he's more than likely
in a game hop to some generic games that
you had you've never heard of because
they're like oh yeah it's a space
shooter but it's not Call of Duty it's
not Gears of War it's not massive fact
and a kart racing game that's not Mario
Kart or the other generic kart racing
games that aren't Mario Kart that
actually exists don't hate in the
comment section although you're going
too seriously though I just love this
premise I have a feeling this might be
step 1 like God willing wreck-it Ralph
is just a really good movie everyone
loves it positive reviews rakes in some
dough other game companies might be like
oh you're making a sequel here use our
use our characters use our world we
love you and in the sequel they might
not need to use like you know generic
game world wide I understand for right
now you can't use all the game worlds
out there but I'm glad to have some
actual game characters but you know for
a fact at a point in the game some hero
from a game has to give Ralph that
speech you know the speech if you're not
gonna find what you're looking for out
there it's in here kinda like what the
zombie says to him in this trailer but
you know a really in-depth version of it
the end game version you know that's
gonna be given by my boy Mario they
really play off this whole video game
aspect this could be like the Super
Smash Brothers of movies and it could
lead to some other game crossover movies
that you never thought were going to be
reality but hey now that might be so I'm
not looking forward to this movie more
than definitely this might not only be
like the Scott Pilgrim of this year but
it might be like this Toy Story for the
Nintendo generation for this generation
that made sense in some realm of the
world that concept of oh you play this
thing then when you turn it off you
think it's done but there's this other
world now come to life and they go on
their own adventure but for video games
and of course the movie that asks the
tough questions applies what video games
become violent and scary
somewhere around Wolfenstein game and
Mortal Kombat I'd say yeah there's what
we do here answer life's tough questions
it looks like if you're a gamer
especially from the Nintendo generation
this is your movie if you're you know
the stepdad is like dog dreams are
nothing don't play games
choose to do some with your life I might
be grasping at straws but this movie
might not be for you
all right so the wreckit-ralph trailer
have you seen it what do you think about
it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more